so one of your goals is to reach the
feeder elo chest rating of 2 900.
maybe you can comment on how's this
rating calculated and
what does it take to get there
is it possible for a human being to get
there basically you play with a factor
of um
10
which means that if i were to play
against
um an opponent who's rated the same as
me i would be expected
to score fifty percent obviously and
that means that i would win five points
with the win uh lose five points with
the draw and then equal if i if i draw
if your opponent is 200 points lower
rated you're expected to score 75
and and and so on
and you establish that rating by playing
a lot of people and then it slowly
converges towards an estimate of how
likely you are to win or lose against
differences yeah and uh my rating is
obviously carried through thousands of
of games um
right now my rating is 28 61
which is decent like i think that pretty
much
corresponds to to the level i have at at
the moment which means in order to reach
2900
i would have to
either get better at chess which i think
is
fairly hard to
to do at least considerably better so
what i would need to do is
try and optimize
even more in terms of
the matchups preparations everything but
not not necessarily like selecting
tournaments and so on but like just
optimizing in terms of
of preparation like making sure i'm
i'm i never have any bad days and you so
you basically can't lose yeah i
basically can't [ __ ] up ever
if i wanna
if if i wanna reach
that goal and so i i think
reaching 2900 is pretty unlikely
the reason i've set the goal is
to have something to to play for to have
like
to have a motivation to
actually try and and be at my best when
i play because otherwise
i'm
playing to some extent mostly for for
fun these days uh in that i love to play
i love to try and win but i don't have
like a lot to
uh i don't have a lot to prove or
anything uh but that gives me at least
the motivation to try and
try and be at my best all the time which
i think is something to um to to aim for
so at the moment i'm quite
enjoying that process of um
uh of trying to um
yeah trying to optimize
you